the 2020 presidential election gave
libertarian voters
few good options a serially dishonest
and incompetent leader
who bungled the covid pandemic and
imposed trade and immigration
restrictions
and a career democrat promising 11
trillion dollars in new spending
who played a role in many of the
greatest policy failures of the last 30
years
such as the war in iraq the patriot act
and the expansion of the drug war
and then there was the libertarian party
america's third largest
after nominating a pair of popular
former governors to run in 2016 who
pulled just over three percent of the
popular vote
the party backed joe jorgensen a clemson
university psychology lecturer
who was featured on the lp ticket in the
1990s but remains largely unknown
outside of libertarian circles so is the
party still a worthwhile project
i am here in favor of dissolving the
libertarian party the best thing
that you can do if you wanted to spread
liberty would not be to run
for the libertarian party the best thing
that you could do would be to run
locally as either a republican or a
democrat reason spoke to
several party insiders about what they
think went right and wrong in 2020
the lp's internal divisions and the
party's strategy for the future
you had something in the jorgensen kohen
ticket that appealed to anybody no
matter where you were in the party
whether
you were sort of on the more radical
side of things the more pragmatic a set
of things
there was something you can latch behind
alex merced is the former vice chair of
the libertarian party
he thinks that even though jorgensen
fell short of johnson's vote share the
unifying effect it had among
libertarians was positive for the
movement
the last few months have probably been
some of the least amount of inner party
conflict that i've seen in a long time
but also
for the most part when i take a look at
jorgensen and spike when they do their
media appearances
they they generally present a positive
message we need to put
the decision-making power back into your
hands
because you can spend your money better
than the politicians and special
interests i think that when you try to
water down your messaging to appeal to
everyone
you sort of appeal to no one angela
mcardle
is the chair of the los angeles
libertarian party who plans to run for
chair of the national party in 2022.
she's affiliated with the mises caucus
which believes libertarians have been
far too willing to compromise their
principles and
water down their rhetoric to make
alliances with the political left or
right
they reject the need to make faustian
bargains in the interest of gaining
mainstream acceptance
she thinks jorgensen began the necessary
process of recalibrating the party
which she says should be less gary
johnson and more ron paul
when you look at the general composition
of the liberty movement
not just the libertarian party it looks
a lot more like ron paul
than it does gary johnson and i don't
know a lot of libertarians who tell me
that they were inspired by gary johnson
did he let people know the party exists
yes but did he light a fire in anyone's
heart
no mcardle believes the best use of the
national party
is to inspire activists to get involved
with the state and local parties where
candidates have a better shot
of actually winning you need to think
about realistically what are the chances
that we're going to just jump up rapidly
and get a third of the vote it's not
likely
i think that it's much more likely that
you would run a principled campaign
and see over the span of 20 years the
grassroots
organizations that support libertarians
libertarian county parties and state
parties
build up their voter base while relying
on national presidential campaigns to
help them the libertarian party does
currently hold
more than 200 elected seats mostly local
positions like treasurer city council
member school board member
or small town mayor according to its
website the most powerful members of the
party holding office are
jeff hewitt riverside county supervisor
who ran in a non-partisan race
and congressman justin amash who wasn't
elected as a libertarian but switched
party affiliations but amash opted not
to run for re-election in 2020.
in the most recent election the party
secured 11 electoral victory so far the
highest office
by a libertarian party candidate in 2020
was won by marshall burt who will join
the wyoming state house in january
current libertarian party chair joe
bishop henchman agrees with mcardle that
electoral success
begins at the local level just imagine
how different the national
political discussion would be if there
was a caucus of
8 or 10 or 12 libertarian senators could
really be significantly changing
what's happening in washington d.c so
how do you get to that
we've got to elect more libertarian
house members in order to get that we've
got to build up a deep bench of
elected officials at the state and local
level and so
how do we get there well it's building
up the infrastructure of the party so we
have people who
know how to elect and re-elect people he
says that while jorgensen did worse
than johnson in 2016 the party has grown
its registration role significantly
which is now at a record 650 000. we've
got
lots of market liberals who are fed up
with the aoc
direction of the democratic party in the
bernie sanders direction that they're
going
and we've got a lot of small government
conservatives who are fed up with the
anti-trade anti-immigration trumpist
direction of that party so there's a lot
of people
who are politically homeless right now
are you hoping that the party will
draw mostly from disaffected democrats
disaffected republicans
people who don't vote at all i'm going
to let the data lead us
to the answer act is the party for
people who
are individualistically minded just
recently in new zealand their
our counterpart party over there the act
party had a very good election result uh
got a whole bunch more seats in
parliament
a lot of other countries the libertarian
party or the classical liberal party
ends up being the
center force uh mitigating the ex the
excesses of the other two parties
libertarians aren't centrists like it's
a very different proposition but i think
it's going to be around that far and
then what's going to happen is that
it's going to be sort of the far left
and far right where we don't
kind of hit but for members of the mises
caucus like mcardle
the more effective strategy is to lean
into radicalism even if it means
potentially alienating centrists
we need someone at the front of the
national party who is not afraid to talk
about issues that are controversial
we need someone who is going to make
libertarian statements
and not worry about offending the left
because why do we waste our time
pandering and begging for votes from a
group of people
who ultimately aren't going to like us
for instance mercado believes the
libertarian party should have
differentiated itself from the democrats
and the gop by taking a strong stance
against the coveted lockdowns by holding
an in-person convention
we're not going to get there if we run
candidates who are afraid to talk about
the issues
if we run candidates who are afraid to
oppose the lockdown
or candidates who are constantly
parroting the virtue signaling of the
left
afraid of sounding too
anti-authoritarian
that's not going to get us there we've
got to speak boldly
several libertarians including mcardle
also criticized the jorgensen campaign's
adoption of black lives matter rhetoric
in a tweet telling her followers it's
not enough to be not
racist but necessary to be actively
anti-racist
oh did they click like on a joe
jorgensen tweet about black lives matter
did they show up to the polls no did
they change their voter registration
no are they really joining the
libertarian party
no the libertarian party needs to
disregard
pc politics if there's a situation that
comes up that we could talk about the
value
of individual black lives we should
absolutely do it
it doesn't mean that we need to co-opt
their language and be afraid of
offending them when we talk about the
ramifications of the drug war
we can just speak the truth because
that's what we should be doing
henchman disagrees with the notion that
the libertarian party has ever had a
problem speaking unpopular truths
we've never really pulled our punches i
mean we were for the decriminalization
of marijuana back when less than 10
percent of america the american people
supported that
we were for equality for gay and sexual
minorities
back when way less than 10 of the
american people supported that
we were for the abolition of the draft
way before it happened
almost any libertarian would be
considered politically radical by the
conventional definition of the terms
for henchmen the focus of the next four
years is getting libertarian party
candidates elected at the state and
local level
our goal is to be a political force
and to try to make that happen in the
political environment
and the way we do that is by electing
people and the way we elect people
is by building up a party that can
deliver the
door-to-door canvassers and the
donations
and the activists who were text banking
and phone banking
in order to make all that happen while
mainstream political commentators might
mostly view joe jorgensen's campaign
as fielding the candidate who was a
spoiler in several close swing states in
2020.
party officials hope the influx of new
members it brought in
pretends a new era for an ascendant
political party
it's time that we get out of startup
mood and that we prove that we can do it